for those of you who are like me who are
still waiting
okay and you're unable to secure
appointments some of you are probably
wondering
where do you turn well i found out
there's a local guy
who says he can help i'm not entirely
sure
but uh well anyway check out his pitch
see what you think
hi i'm rick workman i haven't figured
out a way to get that vaccine yet
don't worry i'll find that vaccine for
you pal just pay me one thousand dollars
through dollar mode
cash buds or bump coin and i will get
you them shots
give you them shots my father was a
vaccine finder
his father was a vaccine finder never
met either of them
don't have a co-morbidity
you do now i just put it in the system
and if anyone denies you from getting
the vaccine
they're gonna have to deny me from
kicking their ass again you ask how will
i get you the vaccine
you simply need to calm down and stop
asking so many questions
want to see some footage of me getting
an appointment
that guy was going to take your shot
instead he took my shot
rick workman
where am i going to find the vaccine i'm
the goddamn vaccine finder aren't i
get your head out of your ass
how did i become the vaccine finder
legend has it
that whomsoever shall pull this sword
from this beanbag that has been left
outside for too long
shall become rick workman vaccine finder
ah it has been for toll
freak work man great
still not sure how that guy's getting
vaccines but he seems trustworthy